[Music]
you're acting in this uh performing in
this show it's getting a lot of critical
attention a lot of people looking at you
your father is a playwright david mamet
and i'm just curious did your dad give
you any acting tips did he give you any
advice that would help you as an actor
um my dad told me um
that acting school was [ __ ]
um and he
uh what a salty language in this house
i'm so sorry
no he actually probably right now is
like goddammit she should watch her
mouth um
i'm learning i'm learning i'm young um
he no he's he's a very straightforward
man he basically um i think his favorite
quote about acting is that jimmy cagney
quote
that he
adores um cagney said something like
hit your mark look the other fella in
the eye and tell him the truth which um
which i think is great which i think is
very succinct simple acting advice and
he um yeah i mean he always said that
creating a character was sort of
nonsense and he always just told me to
learn my lines and show up on time and
do my job and then go home
right
now boiling it down to its essence
pretty much yeah which um which is sort
of what i've what i've tried to do so
not a so not not a method guy who says
pretend you're a carrot and uh you know
spin around in a room no that's just in
life i mean you know we just like we
were brought up to what you mean it's
like a vegetable family you you had a
very
you had a very
you had a very unorthodox upbringing i
did yes and your father encouraged you
to drop out of school and i don't mean
drop out of college he encouraged you to
drop out of high school he did
yeah let's talk about that
yeah i mean
i'm not a lot of parents are saying that
not many are saying hey you should drop
out of high school they're uh no they're
not um did he have a reason why he
wanted you to drop out of high school um
he he didn't like the school that i went
to um which i didn't really either but
um
i i was just really unhappy i hated
school i've always loved learning
obviously i like to read um and not date
um
and uh i would come home every day just
miserable and um
i always knew i wanted to act and so i
sort of felt like i was waiting for my
life to start to start working so i
would come up every day and he would say
how was your day and i would say it was
awful
um i hate school and he would say we'll
drop out i feel like yeah i know i just
i don't feel like i should finish that
this is so bad i love that drop out
what are you doing um
yeah and then we sort of have have talks
about it and it would always end with
maybe like i'll just go literally i
remember um sometimes i would get sick
and he would be fighting with you to
just stay home today and be like no i
have to go
remember that scary time he caught you
preparing for the sats that was terrible
it was awful
now wait a minute it just refreshed my
memory i do think it's illegal to drop
out of high school isn't it i'm i'm a
little bit murky on the exact i didn't
go to law school so i'm not sure um but
i think that if you test out um and
become emancipated then you're good if
you be uh
okay my little sister dropped out this
year she's 17 and she yeah i know she's
the golden child um she made it to 17.
wow
i know
i'm always like you're so much cooler
than me um but she got emancipated when
she was like 15 and then she dropped out
she i think she tested out and she so
far the cops haven't come looking for
her so
so i think i think talking about it on
tv might not be the right way to go
i mean
so some guys at the station house right
now all right let's get down there